[Música]
a lo largo de las décadas unas 20
millones de personas han atravesado las
puertas de graceland para rendir
homenaje a la leyenda de la música el
disfraz
[Música]
fue su c2 a vos la que se tomó las ondas
de mediados de los 50
éxito tras éxito
elvis fue un pionero en llevar la música
afroamericana al mainstream
lo viví
dónde
y sus provocativos movimientos de baile
retratados aquí en una reciente película
biográfica provocaron desmayos entre las
jóvenes y escalofríos en los sectores
más conservadores de la sociedad
[Música]
y aún hoy en todo el mundo elvis sigue
siendo un icono
dónde vamos
cuando es caro
[Música]
antes de convertirse en una de las
estrellas más destacadas del siglo 20
elvis aron presley creció en la pobreza
en tupelo mississippi
es aquí donde recibió las primeras
influencias de rythm and blues el gospel
y la música country al fusionar estos
géneros para crear el sonido único del
rock and roll la carrera de elvis
presley despegó convirtiéndose en el
ídolo de eeuu y vendiendo desde entonces
cientos de millones de álbumes desde su
reclutamiento en el ejército en
1958 pasando por su boda con su esposa
priscilla hasta su posterior actuación
en las vegas' el estrellato de elvis
presley le siguió a todas partes
con su temprana muerte a los 42 años el
rey se convirtió en una leyenda
[Música]